some breaking news concerning the m25
huge tailbacks have been caused on what
is Britain's busiest motorway after
section of road collapsed in heavy rain
flowing overnight maintenance work you
can see part of the problem they're huge
potholes have been appearing close to
Junction 9 of the m25 many of you will
be familiar with that it's in Surrey you
can see there the huge problems it's
causing Friday afternoon heading into
the weekend it's no doubt an area to
best be avoided if you can this
afternoon large potholes there on
Junction 9 of the m25 causing huge
problems for Gatwick as well they've
warm passages of long delays if you're
heading to the airport by car as
spokespersons that we advise you to
allow extra time for your journey or
consider alternative options or public
transport the heavy rain of course over
the course of last night and today
hasn't helped either so you see this
huge tailbacks at quarter to four on
this Friday afternoon is only gonna get
worse going into the evening best avoid
that if you can as I said Junction 9 on
the m25 in Surrey and but I would
imagine it will affect much of that
motorway throughout the evening we'll
keep you updated here on Sky News those
the live pictures there this afternoon